a dramatic end to a 36-hour mutiny
Wagner Chief you have Danny progosian
hailed as a hero by some in roster Von
Dawn as he began his journey into exile
[Music]
Russia's president accused his Wagner
fighters of being backstabbers and
mutineers but they were cheered as they
returned to their field camps
the mercenary's Rebellion against the
Kremlin and defense Ministry appearing
to find support from men and women on
the streets at least in this city in
southern Russia
some of them sharing whatever food and
water they could find with the fighters
but others not so welcoming to Armed men
on their streets
Saturday's events were seen by many as
an extraordinary and an unprecedented
threat to Vladimir Putin's leadership
after capturing the Russian military's
headquarters in rostov online and
heading north for the capital the Wagner
Convoy made a u-turn just 200 kilometers
short of reaching Moscow
they wanted to disband the Wagner
military company we embarked on a March
of Justice on June 23rd in 24 hours we
got to within 200 kilometers of Moscow
in this time we did not spill a single
drop of our Fighter's blood now the
moment has come when blood could be
spilled understanding the responsibility
that Russian blood will be spilled on
one side we are turning our columns
around and going back to field camps as
planned
on a day of turmoil and confusion the
roster Von Dawn train station was packed
with people rushing to leave the city
as they fled others arrived in armored
vehicles it's unclear where the Chechen
Fighters came from but they vowed to
crush the Wagner Mutiny and preserve the
unity of Russia
Wagner's forces seized control of the
kremlin's military headquarters in
roster Von Dawn early on Saturday saying
they're shot down a military helicopter
hours later a Wagner military Convoy
heading north towards Moscow came under
Fire outside the city of voronesh in a
TV address Russia's president accused
The Mercenaries of treason and said
punishment was inevitable
we will protect our people and our
statehood from any threats including
internal betrayal and what we are facing
is betrayal exorbitant Ambitions and
personal interests led to treason
Russia's defense Ministry appealed to
Wagner's fighters to abandon pregosian
saying they'd been tricked into what was
described as their leaders criminal
adventure and participation in an armed
Rebellion 24 hours on and an uneasy
truce prevails it remains to be seen
whether the Insurrection is over once
and for all the crisis in Russia may be
far from over Mike leppel Al Jazeera
well we've got three correspondents
across Russia and Ukraine following this
story Jonah Hall will give us reaction
from Kiev in just a moment and Ali
Hashem is in donets but first let's go
to Juliet shapovalova she's in Moscow
Julia what's been the reaction there in
Moscow this morning we've has seen
checkpoints being removed from the city
but restrictions do remain don't they
yeah they do they do well it seems like
many breathed a sigh of relief of course
but still reeling from the shock uh it's
Sunday a day off in Russia but all shops
cafes Cinemas markets museums Etc all
work as usual here in Moscow everything
looks very quiet people are enrolled in
their weekend activities many are
spending the day in the countryside no
armored vehicles or Personnel in the
center well probably some can still be
spotted uh all the public transport
works too uh by the way traffic
restrictions on the M4 Don Motorway in
the tula and Moscow regions not far away
from here are still in place and there
are some police raids on entrances to
cities they still remain there are
reports that many officials have left
Moscow though but it's not clear for
what reason either due to the Rebellion
or simply because it's vacation time uh
we obviously saw pictures from other
Russian cities like rostov on Dawn West
some people were taking pictures with
Wagner Fighters others were shouting at
them to go away and we also know that
there are still some damaged roads in a
rostov on Dawn there so all that is
being reported a lot of questions
swirling around this Sunday one of the
big ones is what might be the reasons
behind this Mutiny by the Wagner chief
um of course people in Russia tried to
analyze what happened but there is no
one clear version something that
brigosian suddenly gone crazy got out of
control but the state is strong and
people believe in Vladimir Putin support
him and he controls the situation uh
version number two is that precursion is
obviously a player in Vladimir Putin's
political system as all the funds Human
Resources arms and weapons he gets it
comes from the state he totally depends
on Putin despite his rivalry and
disagreements with the ministry of
Defense so some say that pregocia and
Putin are in cahoots and Ferguson plays
a role of a bad guy just to show
everyone that Putin is much better than
him because progression brings fear and
conflict and Putin brings safety
stability prosperity to people all that
means a lot and people have to
appreciate and vote for Mr Putin and
another opinion is that the power system
in Putin's Russia does not work the
president himself does not control
anything he asks a president of another
country to settle the conflict Russian
citizens are completely unprotected and
the security forces and the Army do not
oppose the armed detachments of
mercenaries surrounding cities
surrendering cities without a fight and
having no idea what to do and the
current political system is not stable
and soon or later will collapse which
will bring a lot of uncertainty and
unrest or Civil War so you see the
opinions and dispositions diverge now
absolutely okay Julia for the moment
thanks very much for brings the view
there from Moscow let's go over now to
Donetsk where we can join our
correspondent in the field Ali Hashem
and Ali what is the feeling where you
are how what Wagner fight is reacting to
the deal that turned all of this around
so quickly on Saturday to leave rostov
on and for brigosian to go to Belarus
well in Russo that's around 200
kilometers away from here where the
center of these uh developments were
taking place today People are cleaning
the uh what's left of yesterday's uh
situation and the fighters left some of
them were celebrated by the people some
of them were booed however there are
there is a kind of a people are
questioning the situation questioning
what's to come next and is this the end
to uh the situation of of Wagner and
pregosian himself especially that they
found a kind of uh uh
grounds that are welcoming them in a way
or another and would this be a kind of a
a door for others to challenge the
authority of the of the establishment
and the government these are Big
questions being asked here especially
when you get closer to the peripherals
closer to the to the borders closer to
the front line because all what happened
is was mainly because of the front line
and because of these rivalries between
the Army and the mercenaries so these
are the questions that that are being
asked for now people are cleaning
whatever is left from yesterday's events
and hoping that this is not going to be
repeated in this way okay reporting
there from Donuts thanks very much Ali
or Ukrainian President Vladimir zlensky
has said the situation in Russia shows
that Vladimir Putin is losing control
the man from the Kremlin is obviously
very afraid and probably hiding
somewhere not showing himself I am sure
that he is no longer in Moscow
he calls somewhere and asks something he
knows what he is afraid of because he
himself created this threat well let's
Quest live now to Jonah Hill in Kiev and
Jonah one wonders whether the
extraordinary events of yesterday will
actually make any difference to the war
that's being fought in Ukraine
um
look there's bound to be a degree of
disappointment here in Ukraine that the
changes that so suddenly and
tantalizingly seemed possible as the day
wore on on Saturday didn't happen
tempered though with a real wariness of
what might have been had the evgenic
pregosian prevailed He commands some of
the most combat uh
capable and experienced forces on the
Ukrainian Frontline he's not a man who
would have simply turned his back on the
war remember those events were being
watched here in Ukraine with the same
sense of utter astonishment as they were
being watched all over the world without
many other countries being able to claim
that the consequences would have been
quite as immediately and impactfully
felt as here in Ukraine and I think the
sense that will linger politically and
militarily here and potentially
providing a significant morale boost to
forces on the front line is the sense of
Russia's vulnerabilities exposed
Vladimir zielinski said it early in the
day yesterday
that those events showed that Russia's
weaknesses were obvious
and I think that the other thing that
prevails here is a sense that the
scenario long discussed long envisaged
in the decision-making circles here in
Kiev the idea that the pressures of the
war in Russia would eventually Bear Down
on divisions in the ruling Elite
eventually weighing down on the Kremlin
itself a scenario that seemed like a
distant possibility until just 24 hours
ago will now appear to all to be
something rather more plausible
absolutely okay Jonah many thanks indeed
for joining us there from Kiev